So Paul, let's begin this week's show this way. I want you to explain to me everything you had to go through in order to see the movie Independence Day .
保罗，我们这周的节目就从这里开始吧。我想让你给我讲讲，为了看《独立日》这部电影，你都经历了些什么。
I had to get something to eat. I had to get not only a Coke, but also a juice from somewhere outside of the movie theater and not open it up. I didn't want to have it open. I wanted to have it sealed and have a straw with a paper straw cover around it. Had to sit on the aisle. Had to leave the theater during the previews, and then come back in just as the movie was about to start. Had to wash my hands a couple of times, of course, just in case I had to operate or anything.
我得先找点吃的。我不仅得买可乐，还得从影院外面买点果汁，而且不能打开。我不想让它打开。我希望它是密封的，还得配上一根带着纸质包装的吸管。我必须坐在过道旁。我必须在预告片播放时离开影院，然后在电影刚要开始时再走回来。当然，我还得洗几次手，以防我需要做手术什么的。
Happens a lot in your modern theatres.
在现代影院里这很常见。
Who's already scrubbed? [LAUGHS]
谁已经洗过手了？[笑声]
I've sort of known that I had certain little quirks sometimes when I was watching a movie or really doing anything. But for some reason, I just realized it was going a little too far, that these rituals that I'd developed were just a little bit out of control.
我一直都知道，在看电影或者做任何事情时，我有时会有些小怪癖。但不知为何，我刚才意识到这有点过头了，我养成的这些仪式感已经有点失控了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a topic, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories, documentaries, radio monologues, short stories, found tape, anything we can think of.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会在节目中选定一个主题，为你带来各种各样的故事、纪录片、广播独白、短篇小说、现成录音，任何我们能想到的内容。
Today's program, what happens when a little idea becomes a compulsion? What happens when it starts to control you? Our program today in four acts, four different stories.
今天的节目主题是：当一个小念头变成强迫症时会发生什么？当它开始控制你时会发生什么？今天的节目分为四个篇章，四个不同的故事。
And joining me for this hour is Paul Tough, who actually holds a job. Doesn't just go to theaters freaking out his fellow patrons. Paul Tough, an editor at Harper's magazine in New York and a contributing editor to our show as well. Paul has been thinking and talking to a lot of people about this subject of small obsessions and compulsions.
和我一起主持这一个小时节目的是保罗·塔夫，他可是有正经工作的。他不会只去电影院吓唬其他观众。保罗·塔夫是纽约《哈珀杂志》的编辑，也是我们节目的特约编辑。保罗一直在思考这些关于小癖好和强迫症的主题，并和许多人进行了交流。
And can I just say that your story in the movie theatre-- I mean, those are pretty small things. I mean, all those things seem pretty innocent.
我能说一句吗？你在电影院里的那个故事——我的意思是，那都是些很小的事情。我的意思是，所有这些看起来都很无害。
They are, they are. I mean, none of them are really out of control. I guess one of the reasons they sort of hit me is just because I've been thinking about this a lot. And what struck me about it was that feeling, where suddenly you think, this could become a lot worse. I mean, there are people-- well, OK, I was washing my hands a couple of times before a movie. The movie theaters are kind of dirty places. But there are people out there who wash their hands hundreds of times a day. And what separates me from that person?
确实，确实。我的意思是，它们没有一个是真正失控的。我想它们之所以触动我，是因为我一直在深入思考这个问题。让我感到震惊的是那种感觉，当你突然意识到，这可能会变得更糟。我的意思是，有些人——好吧，我是在看电影前洗了几次手。电影院确实是个有点脏的地方。但有些人一天要洗几百次手。是什么把我与那个人区分开来呢？
A couple hundred times.
几百次。
Exactly.
没错。
There's a numeric number we can assign to that difference.
我们可以给这种差异分配一个数值。
But I had this feeling there in the movie theater that it could happen at any point.
但我当时在电影院里就有种感觉，这种失控可能随时发生。
So Paul, among these cavalcade of stories that you've brought in to play for us over the course of the hour about obsession, I know that some of them are serious and some of them are lighter. What do you want to start with?
保罗，在你为我们带来的这一小时关于强迫症的故事中，我知道有些很严肃，有些则轻松一些。你想从哪个开始？
One of the first people that I talked to is actually someone that I know really well, an ex-girlfriend of mine named Jillian. And what I wanted to talk to her about was her obsession with the number two.
我采访的第一批人中，有一个我非常了解的人，我的前女友，名叫吉莉安。我想和她聊聊她对数字“2”的痴迷。
When she was a kid, just like any kid, she had a favorite number, a favorite color. And her favorite number was two. But it became a lot bigger than that.
小时候，和普通孩子一样，她有最喜欢的数字和颜色。她最喜欢的数字是2。但这变得不仅仅是喜欢那么简单了。
So I started being very preoccupied with doing things twice. If I, for example, dropped keys, I would then lean down and pick them up. But before I actually picked them up, I would probably drop them again. Like really close to the floor so no one would quite know what I was doing. But I'd be very aware that I was fulfilling some sort of two obligation.
所以我开始非常专注于做任何事都要做两次。例如，如果我不小心掉了钥匙，我会弯腰捡起来。但在我真正捡起来之前，我可能会再把它掉一次。动作幅度很小，贴近地面，这样就不会有人注意到我在做什么。但我心里非常清楚，我正在完成某种“2”的义务。
Her obligations weren't all-consuming, but they were somewhat laborious. At the dinner table or in class, she'd say something, and then she'd have to repeat it under her breath to make it two.
她的义务并非全盘占据她的生活，但确实有些繁琐。在餐桌上或课堂上，她说了一句话，然后就得小声重复一遍，好让它凑成两个。
If she made a phone call and the person that she was calling wasn't there, she'd have to let the phone ring an even number of times. She started to see the whole world as being divided into things that were even, things that were on the side of two, and things that were odd.
如果她打了个电话，对方没接，她就得让电话铃响偶数次。她开始将整个世界分为两类：属于“2”那一边的偶数事物，以及奇数事物。
My favorite color was blue, and I also had this fantasy that blue was basically an even color. So it all seemed to fit in. But yellow seemed much more odd to me. And red seemed odd to me. And brown seemed even. Black seemed odd. This doesn't resonate at all with you?
我最喜欢的颜色是蓝色，而且我当时幻想蓝色基本上是偶数颜色。所以这一切看起来很搭。但黄色对我来说显得很“奇”。红色也显得很“奇”。棕色显得是“偶”。黑色显得是“奇”。这跟你一点共鸣都没有吗？
Well, I can see blue being even.
嗯，我可以理解为什么蓝色是偶数。
Tell me a little bit more about the other associations with two. Like you talked about-- I think you told me once that days of the week were as well?
再多跟我讲讲其他关于2的联想。比如你提到的——我想你曾经告诉我，星期几也是这样？
Yeah, days. Both Sunday and Monday seem even to me. But I don't like them as days at all. I much prefer Tuesdays and Thursdays, which seem odd. I mean, days are weird. Monday, Wednesday seems pretty even to me. Tuesday, Thursday, Friday all seem odd.
对，日期。星期日和星期一对我来说都像是偶数。但我一点都不喜欢这两天。我更喜欢星期二和星期四，它们看起来是奇数。我的意思是，日子很奇怪。星期一、星期三对我来说相当偶数。星期二、星期四、星期五看起来都是奇数。
I've got to say, I see it totally differently.
我得说，我的看法完全不同。
You do?
是吗？
Yeah. I see Tuesdays and Thursdays and Saturdays as even, and all the others as odd. I mean Tuesday, first of all-- it kind of goes without saying.
是的。我认为星期二、星期四和星期六是偶数，其他日子是奇数。我的意思是，星期二，首先——这不言自明。
The thing about an obsession like Jillian's is that it can grow to the point where it's not just this game in your head. It can start to really control your behavior. And that's a problem, because that's when people start to notice.
像吉莉安这样的强迫症，问题在于它可能会发展到不仅仅是你脑子里的游戏。它开始真正控制你的行为。那是个问题，因为那时人们就会开始注意到。
Jillian, for instance, she not only had a thing with the number two, she also had a deal with symmetry, where things had to be really symmetrical in terms of her body. If she would touch her left ear, then she would have touch her right ear. Things would have to be very even.
比如吉莉安，她不仅对数字“2”有执念，对对称性也有执念，她的身体必须保持高度对称。如果她碰了左耳，那她就得碰右耳。事情必须非常“偶”。
The big symmetry thing that I can remember is going to a Broadway show with my family. And I had this sense that it didn't feel quite right to just clap with my hands. And so, I developed this thing about clapping with my elbows, with this idea that somehow that would produce a more symmetrical experience. And so, I would clap with my hands, and then clap with my elbows, and then maybe even clap with the entire hand and elbow.
我记得最典型的对称强迫症是有次跟家人去看百老汇演出。我觉得光用手鼓掌感觉不对劲。于是，我发明了一种用手肘鼓掌的方法，因为我觉得那样会产生更对称的体验。所以，我会先用手鼓掌，然后用手肘鼓掌，甚至可能用整个手加手肘一起鼓。
And I can remember just sitting there and someone turning to me and saying, what are you doing? What are you doing with your elbows? And thinking like, this is not normal.
我还记得当时坐在那儿，有人转过头问我：“你在干什么？你的手肘在做什么？”我当时想：这太不正常了。
What I want to ask you about is the relationship between the two thing and other people in your life. And I just sort of remember that there were times when you and I were going out where I would get really mad about the two thing. I mean, do you remember those times when I would get mad about twos?
我想问你的是，关于“2”的强迫症和你生活中其他人之间的关系。我记得我们约会的时候，我有几次因为这个“2”的问题真的非常生气。你还记得我因为“2”而发火的时候吗？
Yeah. But I always felt like your irritation about it was just irrational. I mean, for example, it used to come up a lot with the alarm clock, right? Like, I set my alarm clock usually for 8:02. If I need a little more sleep, then it's 8:12 or 8:22. I don't really like 8:32, but I'll do that.
记得。但我一直觉得你对此的恼火是不理性的。例如，它过去常在闹钟上出现，对吧？我通常把闹钟设在8:02。如果我需要多睡一会儿，那就设在8:12或8:22。我其实不太喜欢8:32，但我会那样设。
But so, when I used to want to set the alarm clock for 8:02, and you would object and want to set it-- I mean, first of all, sometimes you would object. You would just want to set it for 8:03, which was just pure malice on your part. Like, obviously, I'm not going to be happy if the alarm clock is set for 8:03. I mean, what would you really care if I set the alarm clock for 8:02?
所以，当我以前想把闹钟设在8:02时，你会反对，并想设在——我的意思是，首先，有时候你会反对。你就是想把它设在8:03，那完全是出于你的恶意。我的意思是，显然如果闹钟设在8:03我会很不高兴。如果你把闹钟设在8:02，你到底有什么好介意的？
Well, I actually remember that the minute we started talking about it. I actually remember what made me mad about not being able to set the clock for 8:01. Because it is about unnecessarily cluttering your life with things. Spending extra time piling stuff onto your good mood or bad mood just seems totally unnecessary.
嗯，我其实记得那个念头冒出来的瞬间。我记得为什么不能把闹钟设在8:01让我那么生气。因为它让生活平白无故地变得杂乱无章。把额外的时间花在把这些东西堆到你的好心情或坏心情上，看起来完全没有必要。
But you only think about it as piling stuff if it's something that really feels like an obligation. Which the two thing is in a certain way, but it's also just something that you like, or that I like.
但你只有在它感觉像是一种义务时，才会觉得那是“堆东西”。这在某种程度上确实是关于“2”的义务，但这也是一种你喜欢的，或者说我喜欢的东西。
But that's not what would bother me about it. It wasn't just that you would say, oh, 8:02. Oh, you set it for 8:02. That's great. That's going to be fun. It was like, if it was 8:01, you'd go nuts. It wasn't just--
但那不是困扰我的地方。不仅仅是因为你会说：“哦，8:02。哦，你设在8:02。太棒了。那一定很有趣。”而是说，如果是8:01，你就会发疯。不仅仅是——
That's because I realized it was coming out of a sadistic impulse in you.
那是因为我意识到这来自于你内心的一种施虐冲动。
Well, if I just happened to be fast-forwarding through the 24 hours, and then I'd drop it around--
嗯，如果我恰好在24小时里快进，然后把它掉在——
No, you would never just happen to set it 8:01. You would set it and there'd be something very sinister about your setting the alarm clock.
不，你绝不会只是恰好把它设为8:01。你会设好它，而且在你设闹钟的时候，有一种非常阴险的东西在里面。
It only became sinister after I had already felt like you were overdoing it.
只有在我感觉你做得太过火之后，它才变得阴险。
Is this really the place to rehearse this?
这真的是重温这些陈年往事的地方吗？
I mean, there is a way in which I'm addicted to the two thing. And in a way, that's almost as powerful as any other physical addiction.
我的意思是，我在某种程度上确实对“2”成瘾。在某种程度上，这几乎和任何其他生理上的成瘾一样强烈。
And that doesn't bother you?
这不困扰你吗？
No. I think that I actually kind of like it. I mean, I think I like having that kind of order in my life and having routine.
不。我觉得我其实挺喜欢的。我的意思是，我觉得我喜欢生活中拥有那种秩序感，并且有例行公事。
When you would drop the keys and pick them up again, you'd do that sort of quietly, right? So that other people wouldn't think you were doing that?
你掉落钥匙再捡起来的时候，动作很轻，对吧？这样别人就不会认为你在做什么奇怪的事？
Well, I mean, I was clued in enough to know that people would think it would be kind of weird. Your average Joe is not going to be that sympathetic to someone who has an obsession with the number two.
嗯，我有足够的自知之明，知道别人会觉得那很怪异。普通人不会对一个痴迷数字“2”的人产生太多的共鸣。
Although I do think-- the more I talk to people-- I do think people have variations of these things. You talked about it about being a continuum. And on the one side of the continuum, would be the people who you might just label as quirky. And the other side of the continuum would be the people who might have to start taking Prozac, right? And I think-- yeah, I think most people are on the continuum.
虽然我确实认为——我与人交谈得越多——我觉得人们都有这些癖好的变体。你谈到它是一个连续体。在连续体的一端，是那些你可能只会贴上“古怪”标签的人。而另一端，则是那些可能需要开始服用百忧解的人，对吧？我觉得——是的，我认为大多数人都在这个连续体上。
Paul? I mean, sure most people are on the continuum, but that doesn't explain why one particular person-- why Jillian-- would end up with such an extreme set of beliefs and practices and someone else would end up with fewer. Why do you think that she ended up at the point where she is on the continuum?
保罗？我的意思是，当然大多数人都在这个连续体上，但这并不能解释为什么某一个人——为什么吉莉安——最终会陷入如此极端的一套信念和行为中，而另一些人却较少。你认为为什么她最终停在了连续体上的那个位置？
We talked about it a lot. And I don't think either one of us really came up with a definite answer. The one thing I kept thinking about though is, to me, obsessions can sometimes take the place of religion in people's lives. An organized religion gives you certain rules, certain rituals, by which to live your life. Things will be orderly if you follow those rules. And if you grow up in a nonreligious environment, maybe you start creating those rules for yourself.
我们谈了很多。我觉得我们俩都没能得出一个确定的答案。但我一直想的一点是，对我来说，强迫症有时会在人们的生活中取代宗教的位置。一种有组织的宗教为你提供了某些规则、某些仪式，让你以此来生活。如果你遵守这些规则，事情就会有序。而如果你在一个非宗教的环境中长大，也许你就会开始为自己制定这些规则。
You grew up in a pretty atheist household, right?
你在一个相当无神论的家庭长大，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
So do you think that maybe people who grew up in that sort of household, where there weren't a lot of sets of rituals and where it was sort of a hyper-rational household-- you know what I mean? There's no religion. There's two psychologists as parents, who both basically believe that everything can be figured out.
所以你认为，那些在那种家庭长大的人，没有太多的仪式，而且是一个相当“高度理性”的家庭——你明白我的意思吗？没有宗教。父母双方都是心理学家，他们基本上认为一切都是可以算清楚的。
But both you-- and I think your siblings too-- have this tendency towards magical thinking.
但你和你的兄弟姐妹都有这种倾向于“魔法思维”的倾向。
But my siblings and stuff, I don't think they really experienced-- I could imagine that it is a kind of substitute. But if is, then it was pretty specific to me.
但我的兄弟姐妹们，我不觉得他们真正经历过——我可以想象这是一种替代品。但如果是的话，那也确实是我个人的特例。
What about [? Elena ?] and the rubber bands?
那埃琳娜和橡皮筋的事情呢？
What do you know about [? Elena ?] and the rubber bands?
关于埃琳娜和橡皮筋，你知道些什么？
I know that she wore rubber bands around her arm every day for a couple of years or something.
我知道她连续几年每天都在手臂上戴着橡皮筋之类的东西。
And do you know why she wore them?
你知道她为什么要戴吗？
No.
不知道。
I don't know either. I think she wore them-- I mean, she wore a lot of rubber bands. She didn't just wear them around her arm. She wore big rubber bands around her neck too. [LAUGHS] She had lots of rubber bands all the time. And I think she also carried paperclips in her pockets.
我也不知道。我觉得她是戴着——我的意思是，她戴了很多橡皮筋。她不只是戴在手臂上。她脖子上也戴着粗橡皮筋。[笑声] 她随时随地都有很多橡皮筋。我想她兜里还装有回形针。
And that's a hyper-rational thing, your family--
那是一个高度理性的东西，你们的家庭——
I think if you go into any house though, you'll find these kind of things. My mother used to say that having four kids expanded her idea of the normal. Like, what the normal could entail.
我觉得如果你走进任何一个家庭，你都会发现这类事情。我母亲常说，有四个孩子扩大了她对“正常”的定义。比如，什么是正常可能包含的内容。
So Paul, so what else do we have coming up?
所以保罗，接下来我们还有什么？
Well, I've gathered another few stories about obsession. The next one is a little bit further down that continuum. This is one with somewhat more serious consequences.
嗯，我收集了另外几个关于强迫症的故事。下一个故事在连续体上走得更远了一些。这是一个后果稍微严重一些的故事。
Act Two, Further Out. Ira, the thing that's I think a little scary about these compulsions, even the ones that are pretty innocent like Jillian's, is that you feel when you've got them that something else is controlling you. And so, that makes you think that you could just suddenly go over the edge, just because you're out of control. There's a sense that something else is writing the rules.
第二篇章，更进一步。艾拉，我觉得这些强迫症有点可怕的地方在于，即使是像吉莉安那样相当无害的强迫症，你也会在患上时感到有某种东西在控制你。这让你觉得因为你失去了控制，你可能会突然越过那条线。有一种感觉是，有某种东西在书写规则。
So explain what you've got for us next.
那你为我们接下来准备了什么？
Well, this is a story of someone who did go over the edge-- for awhile, anyway. It's by a woman named Lauren Slater, who was a psychologist in Boston. And this is an excerpt from a book that's going to be published soon, which is tentatively titled Black Swans .
嗯，这是一个关于有人越过了那条线的故事——至少有一段时间是这样。它出自波士顿的一位心理学家劳伦·斯莱特之手。这是她即将出版的一本书的节选，暂定名为《黑天鹅》。
And one thing that's really interesting to me about Lauren, especially after having talked to Jillian, is that they sort of started in the same place. As a child, Lauren did a lot of the same compulsive things that Jillian did, had a lot of the same superstitious beliefs and fears. When she walked through a door, she had to tap the frame three times. When she said her prayers at night, between each prayer, she thought she had to close her eyes and then count to 10 and 1/2. But at some point, it went further than that.
关于劳伦，有一点让我非常感兴趣，特别是在采访了吉莉安之后，是她们有点从同一个起点出发。小时候，劳伦做了很多和吉莉安一样的强迫性行为，有很多同样的迷信信念和恐惧。当她穿过一扇门时，她必须拍打门框三次。当她晚上做祈祷时，在每次祈祷之间，她觉得必须闭上眼睛，然后数到10.5。但在某一点上，它走得更远了。
There is something satisfying and scary about making an angel, lowering your bulky body into the drowning fluff, stray flakes landing on your face. I am seven or eight, and the sky looms above me, gray and dead.
在雪地里做一个雪天使，把笨重的身体降入溺水的蓬松雪花中，细碎的雪片落在脸上，这既让人满足又让人害怕。我当时七八岁，天空在上方隐隐显现，灰暗而死寂。
I move my arms and legs, expanding, contracting, sculpting snow before it can swallow me up. I register a mistake on my angel, what looks like a thumb print on its left wing. I reach down to erase it, but am unable to smooth the snow perfectly. So I start again on another angel, lowering myself, swishing and sweeping, rolling over.
我挥动着手臂和腿，扩张、收缩，在雪花吞噬我之前雕琢着。我注意到我的天使身上有一个错误，左翼上看起来像是一个拇指印。我伸手去擦掉它，却无法完美地抹平雪。所以我又开始做另一个天使，把自己降下去，挥动、扫动、翻滚。
No, yet another mistake. This time, the symmetry in the wing span is wrong. A compulsion comes over me. I do it again and again.
不，又是一个错误。这次，翅膀跨度的对称性错了。一种强迫感向我袭来。我一遍又一遍地做。
In my memory, hours go by. My fingers inside my mittens get wrinkled and raw. My breath comes heavily and the snow begins to blue. A moon rises, a perfect crescent curl whose precise shape I will never be able to recreate. I ache for something I cannot name. Someone calls me. Come in now, come in now.
在我的记忆中，几小时过去了。连指手套里的手指变得皱巴巴的，生疼。我的呼吸变得沉重，雪开始变蓝。月亮升起来了，是一个完美的弯月，那种精确的形状我永远无法再现。我渴望着一些我无法命名的东西。有人叫我。“现在进来，现在进来。”
Very early the next morning, I awaken, look out my bedroom window, and see the yard covered with my frantic forms. Hundreds of angels, none of them quite right. The forms twist and strain, the wings seeming to struggle up in the winter sun, as if each angel were longing for escape, for a free flight that might crack the crystal and ice of our still, stiff world.
第二天清晨，我醒来，看向卧室窗外，看到院子里布满了我不顾一切做出的形状。数百个天使，没有一个完全正确。这些形状扭曲而紧绷，翅膀似乎在冬日的阳光下挣扎着，仿佛每个天使都在渴望逃离，渴望一次自由的飞翔，或许能冲破我们那个静止、僵硬世界的水晶与冰层。
Looking back on it now, I think maybe those moments in the snow were when my OCD began, although it didn't come to me full-fledged until my mid-20s. OCD stands for obsessive compulsive disorder, and some studies say over three million Americans suffer from it.
现在回想起来，我觉得也许那些雪地里的时刻就是我强迫症的开端，尽管直到我20多岁时它才完全成熟。OCD代表强迫症，一些研究表明超过三百万美国人患有此病。
Some mental health professionals claim that the onset of obsession is a response to an underlying fear-- a recent trauma, say, or a loss. I don't believe that that is always true. Because no matter how hard I think about it, I remember nothing unusual or disorienting before my first attack.
一些心理健康专家声称，强迫症的发作是对潜在恐惧的反应——比如最近的创伤或损失。我不相信那总是真的。因为无论我如何努力思考，在我第一次发作之前，我不记得有任何异常或令人困惑的事情。
I don't know exactly why at 2 o'clock one Saturday afternoon what felt like a seizure shook me. I recall lying on the floor in my apartment in Cambridge. I was immersed in a book, The Seven Storey Mountain , walking my way through the tale's church. A monk moaned. And suddenly this, a thought careening across my cortex, I can't concentrate.
我不知道为什么在一个周六下午2点，一种类似癫痫发作的感觉震颤了我。我记得躺在剑桥公寓的地板上。我沉浸在一本书中，《七重山》，穿行在书中的教堂里。一个僧侣在呻吟。突然，一个念头在我的大脑皮层掠过：我无法集中注意力。
Of course, the thought disturbed my concentration, and the monk's moan turned into a whisper, disappeared. I blinked, looked up from the book. The floor suddenly frightened me. Between the planks, I could see lines of dark dirt and the sway of a spider crawling.
当然，这个念头干扰了我的专注力，僧侣的呻吟变成了一种耳语，消失了。我眨了眨眼，从书本上抬起头。地板突然让我感到恐惧。在木板之间，我可以看到暗色的泥土线条和爬行的蜘蛛。
Let me get back, I thought, into the world of the book. I lowered my eyes to the page, but instead of being able to see the print, there was the thought blocking out all else-- I can't concentrate.
我得回到书的世界里，我想。我降低眼睛看向页面，但不仅无法看到文字，反而是一个念头遮蔽了一切——我无法集中注意力。
Now I started to panic. Each time I tried to get back to the book, the words crumbled, lost their shapes. I said to myself, I must not allow that thought about concentration to come into my mind anymore. But of course the more I tried to suppress it, the louder it jangled.
现在我开始惊慌了。每当我试图回到书中，文字就会崩塌，失去形状。我对自己说，我绝不能再让关于专注的念头进入我的脑海。但当然，我越是试图压制它，它就越是叮当作响。
I looked at my hand. I ached for its familiar skin. But as I held it out, the sentence, I can't concentrate on my hand, blocked out my hand. So all I saw was a blur of flesh. I tried to force my brain onto other topics, but with each mental dodge, I became aware that I was dodging. And each time I itched, I became aware that I was itching. And with each inhalation, I became aware that I was inhaling. And I thought, if I think too much about breathing, will I forget how to breathe?
我看着我的手。我渴望它那熟悉的皮肤。但当我伸出它时，“我无法专注于我的手”这一句，遮蔽了我的手。所以，我看到的只有一片模糊的肉。我试图强迫大脑去想其他主题，但每次精神闪避，我都能意识到我在闪避。每次我发痒，我都能意识到我在发痒。每次吸气，我都能意识到我在吸气。我想，如果我思考呼吸太多，我会忘记如何呼吸吗？
Say "God I'm sorry" 14 times I ordered myself. This is crazy, I said to myself. 15 times, a voice from somewhere else commanded.
“上帝，我很抱歉，”我对自己下令说14次。这太疯狂了，我对自己说。“15次，”一个来自别处的声音命令道。
In the days after my attack, obsessive thoughts returned. What before had been inconsequential behaviors, like counting to three before I went through a doorway or checking the stove several times before bed, now became imperatives.
发作后的几天里，强迫性的念头卷土重来。曾经无关紧要的行为，比如在进门前数到三，或睡前检查几次炉灶，现在成了必须执行的指令。
There were a thousand and one of them to follow. Rules about how to step, what it meant to touch my mouth, a hot consuming urge to fix the crooked angles of the universe. It was constant, a cruel nattering. There, that tilted picture on the wall. Scratch your head with your left hand only.
有成千上万条规则要遵循。关于怎么走路、触摸嘴巴意味着什么、一种修复宇宙歪斜角度的炽热冲动。这是一种持续的、残酷的喋喋不休。看，墙上那张歪斜的照片。只用左手抓头。
It was noise, the beak of a woodpecker in the soft bark of my brain. I did very little for the next year. I didn't want to go out, because any movement might set off a cycle of obsessions. I sat hunched and lost weight. Fear and grief prevented me from eating much.
那是噪音，像啄木鸟的喙啄着我大脑柔软的树皮。接下来的一年里我几乎什么都没做。我不想出去，因为任何动作都可能引发一轮强迫症。我蜷缩着，体重减轻。恐惧和悲伤使我无法吃太多东西。
When I was too terrified to get out of bed, I checked into the local hospital, where I lay amidst IV drips, bags of blood, murmuring heart machines that let me know someone somewhere near was still alive.
当我恐惧得无法起床时，我住进了当地医院，躺在静脉滴注、血袋和窃窃私语般的心电监测仪中间，这让我知道附近还有人活着。
Then one day, my doctor said to me, there's a new medication called Prozac still in its trial period, but it's 70% effective with OCD. I want to send you to a Doctor Vuckovic. He's one of the physicians doing trial runs. I shrugged, willing to try. I'd tried so much, surely this couldn't hurt. I didn't expect much, though. I certainly didn't expect what I finally got.
有一天，我的医生对我说：“有一种叫做百忧解的新药，仍处于试验阶段，但对强迫症有70%的疗效。我想把你转介给武科维奇医生。他是进行临床试验的医生之一。”我耸耸肩，愿意尝试。我尝试过太多了，这肯定不会更糟。不过我没抱太大希望。我当然没预料到我最终得到了什么。
The pads of paper on Vuckovic's desk are all edged in green and white with the word "Prozac" scripted across the bottom. The pen has "Prozac" embossed in tiny letters. He asks me about my symptoms for a few minutes, and then uses the Prozac pen to write out a prescription.
武科维奇医生桌上的纸垫边缘都是绿白相间的，底部印着“Prozac”字样。钢笔上也用小字体刻着“Prozac”。他问了我几分钟症状，然后用百忧解的笔写下了一张处方。
After a couple of days of nausea and headaches, the Prozac began to work its magic. One morning, I woke up and waited for a command. Touch your nose. Blink 12 times. Try not to think about concentrating. The imperatives came. I could hear them, but from far away, like birds beyond a mountain, a sound nearly silent and easy to ignore.
在几天恶心和头痛后，百忧解开始施展魔力。一天早上，我醒来，等待指令。摸你的鼻子。眨眼12次。试着不要去想专注。指令来了。我能听到它们，但来自远方，像山峦后的鸟鸣，声音几乎微不可闻，很容易忽略。
By the fourth day, I felt so shockingly fine that I called Doctor Vuckovic. I believed he had saved me. "I'm well," I told him. "Not yet. It takes at least a month to build up the therapeutic blood level." "No," I said. "It doesn't." I felt rushing enjoy. "The medicine you gave me has made me well. I've actually never felt better." A pause on the line. "I suppose it could be possible." "Yes," I said. "It's happened."
到了第四天，我感到极其好，我给武科维奇医生打了电话。我相信他救了我。“我好了，”我告诉他。“还没好。血药浓度达到治疗水平至少需要一个月。”“不，”我说，“不需要。”我感到一种涌动的喜悦。“你给我的药让我好了。我实际上从来没感觉这么好过。”电话那头沉默了。“我想这可能是可能的。”“是的，”我说，“它发生了。”
Coming up, the chemistry of obsession. Prozac stops working for Lauren Slater, a beaded kitchen, and more, when our program continues.
接下来，强迫症的化学原理。百忧解对劳伦·斯莱特停止了作用，一个珠饰厨房，更多内容，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And co-hosting with me for this hour is Paul Tough, one of our contributing editors. And he has assembled a number of stories about obsession.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。和我一起主持这一小时节目的是保罗·塔夫，我们的特约编辑之一。他收集了许多关于强迫症的故事。
And right now, we're in the middle of a story by Lauren Slater. And she found herself seized by obsessions, hearing voices that paralyzed her. And then nearly overnight, she found herself cured by Prozac.
现在，我们正处于劳伦·斯莱特故事的中间。她发现自己被强迫症抓住，听到让她瘫痪的声音。然后几乎一夜之间，她发现自己被百忧解治愈了。
How could a drug change my mind so abruptly? My brain wasn't wet clay and paste, as all good brains should be, but a glinting thing crossed with wires. I wasn't human, but machine. No. I wasn't machine, but animal, linked to my electrified biology more completely than I could have imagined.
一种药怎么能如此突然地改变我的思想？我的大脑并不是好大脑所应有的那种湿泥和浆糊，而是一个布满电线的闪光东西。我不是人，而是机器。不，我不是机器，而是动物，与我带电的生物学联系得比我想象的更彻底。
We have come to think lately of machines and animals, of machines and nature, as occupying opposite sides of the spectrum. There is IBM, and then there's the lake. But really, they are so similar. A computer goes on when you push its button. A gazelle goes on when it sees a lynx. Only humans are supposedly different, above the pure cause and effect of the hard-wired primitive world. Free will and all.
最近我们开始认为机器和动物、机器和自然占据了光谱的两端。有IBM，也有湖泊。但实际上，它们非常相似。当你按下按钮，电脑就会启动。当羚羊看到猞猁时，它就会启动。只有人类被认为是不同的，凌驾于由硬接线原始世界组成的纯粹因果之上。自由意志等等。
But no, maybe not. For I had swallowed a pill designed through technology. And in doing so, I was discovering myself embedded in an animal world. I was a purely chemical being, mood and personality seeping through serotonin. We are all taught to believe it's true. But how strange to feel that supposed truth bubbling right in your own tweaked brain pan.
但不，也许不是。因为我吞下了一粒通过技术设计的药丸。在这样做的时候，我发现自己嵌入了一个动物世界。我是一个纯粹的化学存在，情绪和人格通过血清素渗透。我们都被教导相信这是真的。但能感觉到那种所谓的真理在自己那台扭曲的大脑壳里冒泡，是多么奇怪。
Mornings now, I got up early to jog, showered efficiently, then strode off to the library. I was able to go back to work, cutting deli part time at Formaggio's while I prepared myself for divinity school the next year by reading. I read with an appetite, hungry from all the time I'd lost to illness. The pages of the book seemed very white. The words were easy, black beads shining, ebony in my quieted mind.
现在每天早上，我起得很早去慢跑，高效地洗澡，然后大步走进图书馆。我能够回去工作，在Formaggio’s兼职切熟食，同时通过阅读为下一年的神学院做准备。我带着胃口阅读，为因病失去的时间而饥渴。书页显得非常白。字句很容易，黑色的珠子闪闪发光，在我安静下来的脑海中呈现乌木色。
Then one day, as though I'd never swallowed a Prozac pill, my mind seized and clamped and the obsessions were back. I was staying with a family in Appalachia in Kentucky on an oral history project. During my interview with Kat, the mother, I decided to take a break in the sandy yard.
然后有一天，仿佛我从未吞下过百忧解药丸，我的大脑又被抓紧，强迫症又回来了。我在肯塔基州的阿巴拉契亚和一个家庭住在一起，参与一个口述历史项目。在采访母亲凯特时，我决定在沙地院子里休息一下。
It was almost 100 degrees. Chickens screamed and pecked. In one swift and seamless move, Pat's husband, Lonny, reached down to grab a bird. He laid it down on a stump, raised an ax, and cut. The body did its dance. Blood spilled. I ran inside. I took a step forward and then said to myself, don't take another step until you count to 25.
气温几乎有100度。鸡在尖叫和啄食。在一个敏捷而无缝的动作中，帕特丈夫隆尼伸手去抓一只鸟。他把它放在树墩上，举起斧头，切了下去。身体在跳舞。血溅出来了。我跑进屋。我向前迈了一步，然后对自己说，在数到25之前不要再迈下一步。
After I'd satisfied that imperative, I had to count to 25 again, and then halve 25, and then quarter it, before I felt safe enough to walk out the door. By the end of the day, each step took over 10 minutes to complete. I stopped taking steps. I sat on my bed.
在我满足了那个指令后，我不得不再次数到25，然后对25减半，再对它取四分之一，然后才感到足够安全走出门。到一天结束时，每一步都需要10分钟以上才能完成。我停止了迈步。我坐在床上。
"What's wrong with you?" Kat said. "Come out here and talk with us." I tried, but I got stuck in the doorway. There was a point above the doorway I just had to see, and then see again. And inside of me, something screamed, back again, back again.
“你怎么了？”凯特说。“出来和我们聊聊。”我试了，但我被卡在门口。门口上方有一个点，我必须注视它，然后再看一次。我内心深处，有东西在尖叫，回去，回去。
The next morning, a Sunday, Kat told me, "You'll feel better if you come to church with us." She peered into my face, which must have been white and drawn. "Are you suffering from some city sickness?"
第二天早上，一个星期天，凯特对我说：“如果你跟我们去教堂，你会感觉好点。”她凝视着我的脸，我那张脸一定显得苍白而憔悴。“你患上了某种城市病吗？”
"Come to church," Kat said. "We can ask the preacher to pray for you." But I didn't believe in prayer where my illness was concerned. I'd come to think that whatever was wrong with me had a simplistic chemical cause.
“来教堂吧，”凯特说。“我们可以请牧师为你祈祷。”但我不相信涉及我疾病的祈祷。我已经开始认为我身上出了问题有着简化的化学原因。
I woke late one night, fists clenched. It took me an hour to get out of bed, so many numbers I had to do. But I was determined. And then I was walking outside, pushing past the need to count before every step.
一天深夜我醒来，双拳紧握。我花了一个小时才起床，因为我要做太多数字了。但我下定了决心。然后我在外面走，强迫自己克服每一步前都要数的需要。
I'd passed midnight fields, a single shack with lighted windows. Cows slept in a pasture. I rounded the pasture, walked up a hill. And then before me, spreading out in moonlight, a lake. I stood by its lip. My mind was buzzing and jerking. I don't know at what point the swans appeared. White swans, they must've been. But in silhouette, they looked black. And they seemed to materialize straight out of the water.
我经过了午夜的田野，一座有着亮灯窗户的棚屋。牛在牧场里睡觉。我绕过牧场，走上小山。然后在我面前，月光下铺开着一片湖泊。我站在湖边。我的大脑在嗡嗡作响和抽动。我不知道天鹅在什么时候出现。那一定是白天鹅。但在轮廓中，它们看起来是黑色的。它们似乎直接从水中浮现出来。
They rose to the surface as memories rise to the surface of consciousness. Hundreds of black swans, suddenly floating absolutely silent. And as I stood there, the counting seized, my mind became silent, and I watched.
它们浮出水面，正如记忆浮出意识水面。数百只黑天鹅，突然浮动，绝对静谧。当我站在那里时，计数停止了，我的思绪安静下来，我看着。
The swans drifted until it seemed for a few moments that they were inside of me. Seven dark silent birds, 14 princesses, a single self swimming in a tepid sea. I don't know how long I stood there, or when exactly I left. The swans disappeared eventually. The counting, ticking, talking of my mind resumed.
天鹅漂流着，直到有几秒钟我觉得它们就在我体内。七只漆黑静谧的鸟，14位公主，一个孤独的自我游曳在温热的海洋里。我不知道我站在那里多久，也不知道我到底什么时候离开的。天鹅最终消失了。我大脑的计数、滴答、说话声又开始了。
Still, even in shattering illness, I had been quieted for a bit. Doors in me had opened. Elegance had entered. This thought calmed me. I was not completely claimed by illness. Nor was I a prisoner of Prozac, entirely dependent on the medication to function. Part of me was still free, a private space not absolutely permeated by pain. A space I could learn to cultivate.
尽管如此，即使在破碎的疾病中，我也安静了一会儿。我内心的门打开了。优雅进来了。这个念头让我平静。我并没有完全被疾病占有。我也不是百忧解的囚徒，完全依赖药物运作。我的一部分仍然是自由的，一个不完全被痛苦渗透的私人空间。一个我可以学习耕耘的空间。
It is a smaller space than I would have wished for myself. Even after I raised my dose, the Prozac never worked as well as it once had. And years later, I am sometimes sad about that. Other times, strangely relieved, even though my brain is hounded. I still must check my keys, the stove. I must pause many times while I write this and do a ritual count to 30.
这比我为自己期望的空间要小。即使在我增加了剂量后，百忧解的效果也从未像曾经那样好。多年后，我有时对此感到悲伤。其他时候，却感到奇怪的解脱，即使我的大脑备受折磨。我仍然必须检查钥匙，炉灶。我必须在写这些时多次暂停，并做一个仪式性的计数到30。
It's distracting to say the least. But still, I write this. I can walk, and talk, and play. I've come to live my life in those brief stretches of silence that arrive throughout the day. I am learning something about the single moment. How rife with potential it is. How truly loud its tick.
至少可以说，这很让人分心。但尽管如此，我还是写下了这些。我可以走路、说话和玩耍。我已经学会了在全天间歇出现的简短静谧时刻中生活。我正在学习关于“当下”的事情。它是多么充满潜力。它的滴答声是多么真实。
Lauren Slater is a psychologist and writer in Boston. This story is excerpted from her upcoming book, Black Swans . And also, Paul, you guys are going publish this in Harper's in September, right?
劳伦·斯莱特是波士顿的心理学家和作家。这个故事节选自她即将出版的书《黑天鹅》。而且，保罗，你们打算九月份在《哈珀》上发表这个，对吧？
That's right.
没错。
OK. Lauren Slater's also the author of Welcome to my Country , which is published this year by Random House.
好的。劳伦·斯莱特也是《欢迎来到我的国家》的作者，该书今年由兰登书屋出版。
Act Three, Sacred Versus Profane. I'm Ira Glass, here with Paul Tough. Paul, welcome back.
第三篇章，神圣与世俗。我是艾拉·格拉斯，和保罗·塔夫在这里。保罗，欢迎回来。
Thank you, Ira.
谢谢你，艾拉。
And Paul is one of the contributing editors to our program, also a writer and a senior editor at Harper's magazine. Each week in our program, of course, we choose a theme and do a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. And Paul, you have been gathering the stories for this week's show. And the theme is, those who just are tuning in--
保罗是我们节目的特约编辑之一，也是一名作家和《哈珀》杂志的高级编辑。当然，我们每周都会在节目中选定一个主题，并围绕该主题进行各种各样的故事报道。保罗，你一直为本周的节目收集故事。主题是，对于那些刚调过来的听众——
We're talking about obsession, and the compulsions and rituals that go along with it.
我们在谈论强迫症，以及与之伴随的强迫行为和仪式。
So you have kind of a meta-obsession going. Sort of an obsession with obsessions.
所以你有一种元强迫症。某种对强迫症的强迫执念。
Exactly. I'm obsessed with the obsessed of all sorts.
没错。我对各种各样痴迷的人都很着迷。
At least for the purposes of this hour. And as you've been putting this show together over the last few weeks, you've been saying that these kinds of compulsions that we're hearing about share a lot with religion.
至少在这一小时里是这样。在你过去几周制作这档节目时，你一直在说，我们听到的这类强迫症与宗教有很多共同点。
Yeah. I think there are certain similarities. And I think that just as religions can help people sort of find order in a chaotic world, some of these rituals that people create for themselves do the same thing.
是的。我认为有一些相似之处。我认为，正如宗教可以帮助人们在混乱的世界中找到秩序一样，人们为自己创造的某些仪式也起到了同样的作用。
This reminded me-- when we've talked about this-- this reminded me of something that I learned in Hebrew school as a kid. Let me get some music going there. [MUSIC PLAYING] There we go. This music was always playing when I was a child, Paul. in the schtiebl in Baltimore.
这让我想起了——当我们谈论这个时——让我想起了我小时候在希伯来学校学到的东西。让我放点音乐。[音乐播放] 好的，就是这样。当我还是个孩子时，这音乐总是在巴尔的摩的犹太会堂里播放，保罗。
This is the Glass household, pretty much.
这差不多就是格拉斯的家庭。
Anyway, what it reminded me of is this thing that I learned that in traditional Judaism-- and you'll still see very religious Jews do this. That in that kind of Judaism, nearly every act of human life is accompanied by some kind of ritual, or a thanks to God, or a prayer, including putting on clothes, washing your hands, using the bathroom, strict rules about what you can eat and how you eat it. You know, the Kosher laws. Rules on covering the head. A religious Jew kisses the mezuzah on the door frames in his own home when he enters and leaves a room. Plus all sorts of prayers and blessings.
总之，它让我想起了我学到的东西，在传统犹太教中——你仍然会看到非常虔诚的犹太人这样做。在那类犹太教中，人类生活的几乎每一个行为都伴随着某种仪式、对上帝的感谢或祈祷，包括穿衣、洗手、上厕所，关于你能吃什么、怎么吃的严格规定。你知道，犹太洁食法。遮住头的规定。一个虔诚的犹太人在进出房间时会亲吻自己家门框上的门框经文盒。外加各种祈祷和祝福。
If we hear lightning, there's a blessing for that. If we see thunder, there's a blessing for that. If we hear bad news during the day, there's a blessing to bless the true judge. If we hear good news, depending on what type of good news, we might say, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
如果我们听到闪电，会有相应的祝福。如果我们看到雷声，会有相应的祝福。如果我们白天听到坏消息，会有祝福来赞美真理之审判者。如果我们听到好消息，取决于好消息的类型，我们可能会说……
This is Mayer Silber, 35 years old, father of three, a member of the Chabad Hasidic Community here in Chicago. He's a litigator for the local district council of the IRS. He was gracious enough to come in and talk to me about the similarities and differences between the hundred rituals that he does as a religious Jew every day, and the more secular rituals that you've been talking about, the people you've interviewed, Paul, have been talking about over the course of the hour so far.
这是梅耶·西尔伯，35岁，三个孩子的父亲，芝加哥查巴德哈西德社区成员。他是国税局当地区议会的诉讼律师。他很慷慨地来和我就他每天作为虔诚的犹太人所做的百种仪式，与你所谈论的、保罗你在这一小时节目中采访的人所谈论的世俗仪式之间的异同进行了交流。
And when he came in, I described a bunch of these kind of daily compulsive rituals to him. Jillian's having to do things in twos-- dropping her car keys and then having to drop them a second time. Or Lauren Slater's having to count to 30 every now and then before she can allow herself to move forward in any task. And Mayer Silber said, really, he only sees one similarity between what they're doing and what he does.
当他进来时，我向他描述了一堆这类日常强迫仪式。吉莉安不得不做两遍的事——掉落车钥匙，然后不得不掉落第二次。或者劳伦·斯莱特在允许自己执行任何任务前不得不数到30。梅耶·西尔伯说，真的，他只看到他们所做的和自己所做的事之间有一个共同点。
I would only say that it's just the capability to be devout to something. I think maybe we should go onto the differences from there. And I guess it sounds like, the way you described them, and I may be wrong, that these people are imprisoned by certain actions. I don't feel imprisoned. I don't feel compelled to say, oh, I can't be in a car from sundown on Friday to sundown on Saturday. I look at it as freedom.
我只会说那是对某件事保持虔诚的能力。我想也许我们应该从那里谈到差异。我想听起来，按照你描述的方式，我可能错了，这些人被某些行为囚禁了。我没有感到被囚禁。我不觉得被迫说，哦，我不能在周五日落到周六日落之间开车。我把它视为一种自由。
One interesting difference between Mayer and the people who we've heard about so far in the program is that when Mayer goes through his daily rituals-- when any religious person, I guess, goes through their daily rituals-- it connects him to a tradition, to the Bible, to the Torah, to his family, to his people. Whereas the people who we've heard in the show up 'til now, when they go through the day with their very obsessive rituals, it doesn't connect them to anyone else. Their path is just a lot more lonely.
梅耶与我们在节目中听到的至今为止的人们之间一个有趣的区别是，当梅耶经历他的日常仪式时——我想任何宗教人士都是这样——它将他与传统、与圣经、与托拉、与他的家人、与他的人民联系在一起。而我们目前在节目中听到的人，当他们带着非常强迫性的仪式度过一天时，它并没有将他们与任何人联系起来。他们的道路要孤独得多。
Do you obey the Commandments our of fear that something bad will happen if you don't?
你遵守戒律是出于担心如果不这样做坏事会发生的恐惧吗？
I would say that I do. Yes. To be honest.
我会说我确实是这样。是的。老实说。
What's the bad thing that would happen?
会发生什么坏事？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, I guess maybe it's the fear of not knowing. The fear of not belonging. Sort of like this abandonment, that maybe with my abandonment of God, God would abandon me. And I would be alone. And I'd be responsible for myself. Where here I feel like if I can go and do the things that God wants, God is with me.
哦，我想也许是害怕“不知道”。害怕“不属于”。有点像这种遗弃感，也许随着我对上帝的背弃，上帝也会遗弃我。我会一个人。我会对自己负责。而在我看来，如果我能去按照上帝想要的去做，上帝就与我同在。
Ira, one thing that I find kind of interesting is that even though Mayer is describing how different he is from Jillian, say, I think there are a lot of similarities between how they see their worlds.
艾拉，我发现一件很有趣的事，即使梅耶描述了他和吉莉安有多么不同，但我认为他们在看待世界的方式上有很多相似之处。
I think that, especially when he was talking about his fears, I think Jillian's are a lot the same way. It's not that she's terrified of the number two. But she--
我认为，尤其是当他谈到他的恐惧时，我认为吉莉安的恐惧方式很像。并不是她害怕数字2。但她——
She's not afraid of the wrath of two. Just like he's not afraid of the wrath of God coming down on him if he doesn't obey the Commandments.
她并不害怕2的愤怒。就像如果他不遵守戒律，他不害怕上帝的愤怒降临在他身上一样。
But I think that she feels like it's kind of a dangerous world, and it helps to have something on her side. In her case, it's the number two. I think just like he said that he'd feel sort of lonely or separated if he disobeyed God, in the same way I think Jillian would really miss the number two.
但我认为她觉得这是一个危险的世界，能有什么东西站在她这边会有帮助。在她的例子中，就是数字2。我想正如他说如果他不听从上帝，他会感到孤独或被分离一样，我也认为吉莉安会真的想念数字2。
Act Four, Heroic Obsessions.
第四篇章，英雄式的强迫症。
Now Ira, one thing about the way that we judge obsessions is how successful the person is. I mean, take Michael Jordan. In every way, he's a completely obsessed person. He's obsessed with winning, to what we'd consider to be a really unhealthy degree if he wasn't such a good basketball player. I mean, it's just lucky that he is able to carry the team on his back whenever he needs to and actually win. If not, he'd be up on a freeway overpass somewhere.
艾拉，关于我们评价强迫症的一点是该人有多成功。我的意思是，看看迈克尔·乔丹。他在方方面面都是一个彻底的强迫症患者。他痴迷于赢，如果他不是一名这么出色的篮球运动员，我们可能会认为他患有非常不健康的强迫症。我的意思是，幸运的是，他能够在需要时背负球队并真正赢球。如果不是这样，他可能会是在某个高速公路立交桥上的某个人。
Right, exactly. If the story of obsession could be subsumed in a larger story of heroism and glory, then the obsession-- nobody even pays attention to it.
对，没错。如果强迫症的故事能被纳入一个关于英雄主义和荣耀的更大故事中，那么这个强迫症——根本没人会去关注它。
Right.
对。
Well, this leads us to our next two stories here on our show. This is the work of two people who've immersed themselves in their own particular obsessions. And people at home can judge for themselves with what results.
好了，这把我们引向了我们节目中接下来的两个故事。这是两个沉浸在自己特殊强迫症中的人的作品。家里的人可以自己评判结果如何。
This first piece of work is one of the stranger things, I have to say, we've ever put on the show. A guy named Greg Whitehead has been collecting the sound of people screaming-- and their thoughts about the meaning of different kinds of screams-- for years all over the world. He sets up these special phone lines that people call into. He's set up a thing called The Institute of Scream Studies.
第一件作品是我不得不说我们节目中有史以来最奇怪的事情之一。一个叫格雷格·怀特黑德的人多年来一直在世界各地收集人们尖叫的声音——以及他们对不同种类尖叫含义的思考。他设置了这些人们拨打的特殊电话专线。他创办了一个叫“尖叫研究中心”的东西。
A scream is often treated as some kind of insurmountable, impenetrable obstacle, pure, white noise force, that is beyond analysis and unworthy of any kind of interpretation. But here at the institute, we hear the scream from entirely the other perspective-- the scream as an opening, as an entry point, as an access point. An entry into a vast interior landscape that has as its surface this highly nuanced, very individual, psycho-acoustic force to it.
尖叫经常被视为某种不可逾越、无法穿透的障碍，一种纯粹的白噪音力量，超出了分析范围，不值得任何形式的解释。但在本中心，我们从完全不同的角度倾听尖叫——尖叫作为一种开启，作为一个切入点，作为一个访问点。进入一个广阔的内部景观，其表面具有这种高度细微、极具个人色彩的心理声学力量。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫]
There's also a scream line, the actual journey that the screamer takes into the interior landscape. And when we established the telephone answering machine here at the institute, we called it the "scream line," because that machine was going to circulate individual scream lines into--
还有一条尖叫线，即尖叫者进入内部景观的实际旅程。当我们在本中心建立电话答录机时，我们称之为“尖叫线”，因为那台机器将把个人的尖叫线路循环进入——
Thank you, Mr. Whitehead. I believe you are on the wrong track. I'm sure if you came to my house, you would hear the screams that you'd never want to hear again. [LOUD SCREAMING]
谢谢你，怀特黑德先生。我相信你走错路了。我相信如果你来我家，你会听到你再也不想听到的尖叫声。[大声尖叫]
[SCREAMING] Oh, I feel much better now. Thank you.
[尖叫] 哦，我现在感觉好多了。谢谢。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫]
Hi. I'm [? Melia Mangum. ?] I'm eight years old, and here's my scream. [SCREAMING] Bye.
嗨。我是[梅利亚·曼格姆]。我八岁，这是我的尖叫。[尖叫] 再见。
The scream--
尖叫——
Hi. It's kind of early in the morning to scream. So I don't think I'll scream, but I'm going to tell you a story. I was thinking about how screams sometimes come later, much later, like a kind of delayed reaction.
嗨。现在是清晨，不太适合尖叫。所以我不想尖叫，但我会讲个故事。我一直在想尖叫有时来得较晚，晚得多，像是一种延迟反应。
So this is a true story that happened long ago when I was a teenager. And I was on this train. Like, I'd run away I think with this guy. And we were on this train. And we'd been going for days and nights. And it had got really steamy on this train. And it's kind of a seedy atmosphere. And everybody was playing cards. All the time, playing cards and smoking.
所以这是一个很久以前发生在我青少年时期的真实故事。我在火车上。我想我和这个家伙私奔了。我们在火车上。我们已经走了好几天几夜。火车上变得非常闷热。这是一种有点肮脏的气氛。每个人都在玩牌。一直在玩牌和抽烟。
And then suddenly, this fight broke out. Like, out of nowhere. First, it was just these sounds. It was, like, really muffled sounds. Bodies colliding and ricocheting down the corridors and stuff. And then these kind of muffled shots.
然后突然，爆发了一场争斗。就像凭空出现一样。起初，只有那些声音。就像是非常沉闷的声音。身体在走廊里碰撞和弹射之类的。然后是那些沉闷的枪声。
And we pulled the door across our compartment, and this body kind of rolled over, rolled past, stumbled past. And there was blood just smeared all over the glass. And you couldn't see anything because of that. It's like the sounds and the vision, and everything was muffled.
我们把车厢门拉过来，这时一具尸体滚了过来，踉跄着滚过去。玻璃上到处溅满了血。因为那个你什么也看不见。就像声音和视觉，一切都被掩盖了。
But it took hours and hours before we reached the next town, and we're going through this small desert. But when we eventually got there, the train stopped. And there was this scene kind of took place in absolute silence. It was extraordinary. No one seemed to speak. And it was incredibly hot and hazy. And there was just this desert all around.
但我们又花了好几个小时才到达下一个城镇，我们穿过这片小沙漠。但当我们最终到达那里时，火车停了。在那儿发生了一幕绝对静谧的场景。太不可思议了。没人说话。而且非常热，雾蒙蒙的。周围只有沙漠。
And they took the body off the train. And then the guy who'd killed him was taken off with handcuffs. And these few cops appeared from nowhere. And it was just like this platform in the middle of nowhere. I mean suddenly, out of the silence, this scream came. It was just like something between a wail and a scream. And it's like it just went right through the whole landscape.
他们把尸体抬下火车。然后杀人的人被戴上手铐带走。那几个警察从虚无中出现。那就像是在虚无中的一个站台。我的意思是，突然间，在寂静中，这声尖叫传了出来。就像是哀号和尖叫之间的东西。它似乎直接穿透了整个景观。
And it's like the dust sort of settled in the air as the scream kind of just hung there. It just seemed like for ages. I don't know if I can do that scream. I can hear it really, really clearly. I'll try, but I think it won't be like that. Anyway, it was something like this. [SCREAMING]
当尖叫声悬在那里时，灰尘似乎在空气中沉降了。似乎持续了很久。我不知道我能不能重现那声尖叫。我可以听得非常、非常清楚。我会尝试，但我认为不会像那样。总之，它听起来像这样。[尖叫]
That compendium of screams from Greg Whitehead of the Institute for Scream Studies. He invites your screams and your thoughts about screamings. And if we get together enough of these from around the country, he's going to put together a second compendium of screams for some later show that we'll play.
以上是来自尖叫研究中心的格雷格·怀特黑德带来的尖叫合集。他邀请你们的尖叫以及对尖叫的思考。如果我们收集到足够多全国各地的这些内容，他会为之后的节目整理出第二部尖叫合集来播放。
So a little radio experiment. Here is the phone number to call. Call 312-832-3326. Again, 312-832-3326. We're serious about this. Call, scream, and talk about screams. And Paul, while people are dialing--
一个小小的广播实验。这是拨打的电话号码。拨打312-832-3326。再重复一遍，312-832-3326。我们是认真的。拨打，尖叫，并谈论尖叫。保罗，当人们拨号时——
Well, the next person that I talked to is an artist in San Diego named Liza Lou. And she is another obsessed person who has a heroic narrative of obsession. For five years, she had a ritual that she did every day. She would get up in the morning, get dressed, get ready to go about her day, and then sit down at her studio with tweezers, and white glue, and tens of thousands of tiny little beads. And she would spend the whole day gluing them down into patterns. And at the end of five years, she'd created this amazing work of art.
嗯，我采访的下一个人是圣地亚哥的一位艺术家，名叫丽莎·娄。她是另一位拥有英雄式强迫叙事的强迫症患者。五年来，她每天都有一个仪式。她早上起床，穿好衣服，准备开始一天的生活，然后坐在画室里，用镊子、白胶和数万颗微小的珠子。她会花一整天时间把它们粘成图案。五年后，她创作出了这件令人惊叹的艺术品。
I haven't had much luck describing this work. What does that mean, a beaded kitchen? You imagine a beaded skirt or a beaded top. The best I can do is I can say, this is a three-dimensional room. It's 200 square feet. It's painted. But it's painted with beads that you have to apply with the tweezers one at a time.
我描述这件作品时不太走运。什么是“珠饰厨房”？你想象一条珠饰裙或珠饰上衣。我能做到的最好描述是，这是一个三维房间。它有200平方英尺。它是涂漆的。但它是用必须用镊子一颗一颗贴上的珠子来“涂漆”的。
So it's this amazing amount of color. It's pinks and blues and silvers and golds. Imagine a wood grain counter in your kitchen. Only suddenly, instead of brown wood, it's become golden and yellow and burnt copper.
所以这是惊人的色彩量。有粉色、蓝色、银色和金色。想象你厨房里的木纹柜台。突然间，它不再是棕色的木头，而是变成了金黄、亮黄和焦铜色。
There's a table in the middle of the kitchen with a bright beaded tablecloth. On the table are a plate of pancakes that's beaded, and a cereal box that's beaded, and toast and bacon and a newspaper-- all of them beaded.
厨房中间有一张桌子，上面铺着闪亮的珠饰桌布。桌上有一盘珠饰薄煎饼、一盒珠饰谷物、吐司、培根和报纸——它们全都是珠饰做的。
Behind the table, there are beaded cupboards, a beaded fridge, cookbook, stove. Every surface is covered with tens of thousands of beads. And the effect is one of unbelievable color. The whole place seems like it's plugged in. It's just shining. Nothing's bare. There's even a beaded dustpan on the floor that's filled with beaded dust.
桌子后面有珠饰橱柜、珠饰冰箱、食谱、炉灶。每一个表面都覆盖着数万颗珠子。效果是令人难以置信的色彩。整个空间看起来像通了电。它闪闪发光。没有任何地方是裸露的。地板上甚至有一个珠饰簸箕，里面装满了珠饰灰尘。
The thing about an obsession is you never know where it's going to lead. One minute, you're just a regular person collecting autographs or saving string or trying to keep clean. And then, something just overtakes you. For Liza-- and I think for a lot of people-- you reach a point where it's suddenly not so much fun. It's a job. It's a duty.
强迫症的一点是你永远不知道它会导致什么。一分钟前，你还是一个收集签名、保存线头或试图保持清洁的普通人。然后，某种东西就会接管你。对丽莎来说——我认为对许多人来说——你会达到一个点，突然间它不再那么有趣了。它是一项工作。它是一种职责。
I didn't think about it. I thought it would take about six months to do when I started. I didn't think it would take so much. I didn't realize it would take my life. It's like falling in love, maybe. It's a form of where you watch you life-- you watch everything else fall away. You lose everything in a sense.
我没想过。我开始的时候以为只要六个月就能做完。我没想到它会花那么多时间。我没意识到它会占用我的生活。这就像坠入爱河，也许吧。这是一种形式，你看着你的生活——你看着其他一切都分崩离析。在某种意义上，你失去了一切。
For five years, I was in the constant stage of to-do lists. Of stress and pressure, and always feeling like a failure. Because every day you feel as though you've got nothing done. You maybe get five inches of work done-- five inches of an entirely beaded kitchen.
五年来，我一直处于持续的待办事项阶段。压力和紧迫感，总是觉得自己是个失败者。因为每一天你都觉得好像一事无成。你可能只完成了五英寸的作品——整个珠饰厨房的五英寸。
So you really felt like a failure every day for five years?
所以五年里你真的每天都觉得自己是个失败者？
It's such a personal problem. I mean, yeah. I always would feel like I didn't get enough done. I never had the feeling of, wow, did I just really do well today. Maybe I'll work an 18-hour day. And then maybe I'll continue to do that for two weeks. So how much time did that take? I don't clock in.
那是一个非常私人的问题。嗯，是的。我总是觉得我没完成足够多的工作。我从来没有过“哇，我今天真的做得很好”那种感觉。也许我会工作18个小时。然后也许我会连续两周那样做。那花了多少时间？我不打卡。
How many days in those five years did you not work on it at all?
五年里有多少天你完全没做？
I don't know. I don't know. And I don't know how much it cost me to do it. I don't know. If I knew those answers, I wouldn't do it. Nobody who thinks like that would bead a kitchen.
不知道。我不知道。而且我不知道做它花了多少钱。我不知道。如果我知道那些答案，我就不会去做了。没有那种想法的人会去装饰一个珠饰厨房。
The wall panels were really challenging. Because the curiosity is the thing that motivates me. I'm not patient, I'm curious. So I already knew-- once I had done one wall panel, I knew what it was going to look like. Then I had to do nine more or eight more panels. And then they all get put together. And that was really difficult.
墙板确实很有挑战性。因为好奇心是激励我的东西。我没耐心，我好奇。所以我已经知道了——一旦我做了一个墙板，我就知道它看起来会是什么样子。然后我不得不做九个或八个板子。然后它们都被组装在一起。那真的很困难。
I would wonder, god, why am I so depressed? And then, finally, I stood the whole wall up and I realized, my god, no wonder I've been depressed. I've been doing the same pattern for the last three months.
我会想，天哪，为什么我这么抑郁？然后，最终，我把整面墙竖起来，我意识到，天哪，难怪我一直很抑郁。我过去三个月一直在做同一个图案。
She didn't have any grants or patrons when she was working on the kitchen. So to make ends meet, she'd have to sell pieces of her work from time to time. And, of course, the pieces that she'd sell would be beaded. They would be pieces from the kitchen. And in fact, she says that she's probably sold the equivalent of the kitchen. There's sort of another entire kitchen out there in various people's homes. So she'd have to bead in order to buy beads in order to bead.
她在制作厨房时没有任何资助或赞助人。为了维持生计，她必须不时卖掉她的作品。当然，她卖掉的作品都是珠饰。它们是厨房的一部分。事实上，她说她卖掉的相当于一个厨房。在各种人的家里还有另一个完整的厨房。所以她必须做珠饰才能买珠子，再为了买珠子而去买珠子。
It's one step backward, and then another step forward, hopefully. Hopefully, it would buy two months in the studio-- one sale or two sales. And the problem with my work is that it takes so long. So selling a soup can wouldn't just set me back a day. It would set me back maybe several weeks.
这就像退后一步，希望能向前一步。希望它能买画室里的两个月——一笔或两笔销售。我的作品的问题在于它花费的时间太长。所以卖掉一个汤罐头不仅仅会让我退后一天。它会让我退后几个星期。
For a long time, I resented how hard it was. This didn't seem right. I mean, nobody who works at I. Magnin has to work at I. Magnin in order to then work at I. Magnin. Do you know what I mean?
很长一段时间里，我很怨恨它有多么困难。这看起来不对。我的意思是，没有人去I. Magnin百货工作，为了在那儿工作再去那儿工作。你明白我的意思吗？
She was living in LA a couple of years ago, and there was an earthquake that almost destroyed the building that her studio was in. I got this phone call in the middle of the night. I had an apartment where basically they were locking the studio out, where you would lose everything.
几年前她住在洛杉矶，那里发生了一场地震，差点摧毁了她工作室所在的建筑。我在半夜接到了这个电话。我住的公寓，基本上他们锁住了工作室，你会失去一切。
They did this to doctors' offices. They lost all their files. Because once a building is condemned, they lock it out, and you can't get back in. So there was this moment where I didn't know if I was going to lose three years of work.
他们对医生的办公室也是这么做的。他们丢失了所有文件。因为一旦建筑被定为危房，他们就会锁住它，你就进不去了。所以有那么一刻，我不知道我是否会失去三年的心血。
And if I had lost it, if it had gotten locked out, I wondered, would I do it again? Would I make that table again? But thankfully, I had time. We had two hours to get everything. And a bunch of friends came and we just shoved everything. And this work is so fragile. Can you imagine doing this in two hours? But we got everything in the truck. And I ended up moving even further south to San Diego.
如果我失去了它，如果它被锁住，我想，我会再做一次吗？我会再做那张桌子吗？但谢天谢地，我有时间。我们有两个小时的时间来搬走一切。一群朋友来了，我们只是把东西乱塞。这件作品太脆弱了。你能想象在两个小时内完成吗？但我们把一切都搬进了卡车。我最终搬得更远，去了圣地亚哥。
So did you ever answer that question for yourself, about what you would have done if it was destroyed?
所以你有没有为自己回答那个关于如果它被摧毁了你会怎么做的问题？
Oh, thank god I didn't have to answer that question.
哦，谢天谢地，我没必要回答那个问题。
The thing is, people think I'm patient. And I'm not patient. I'm tremendously impatient. But I'm very, very curious. Just to point of death, I'm curious. I wanted to know what it would look like to bead a table. That's what got me through it. It's the same pattern. It's a pink and silver and blue pattern, again and again and again and again. But what sustained the interest was, what will it look like when it's finished?
关键是，人们认为我有耐心。但我没有耐心。我非常、非常没有耐心。但我非常非常好奇。好奇到死的程度。我想知道装饰一张桌子会是什么样子。这就是我坚持下来的原因。那是同一个图案。这是一个粉色、银色和蓝色的图案，一遍又一遍又一遍又一遍。但维持兴趣的是，完成后它会是什么样子？
So if I had lost the piece, and I knew what it took to do the piece, and I already knew what it looked like, why would I do it again? What would be the motivating factor? Would that be to make it so that you could see it? I'm not sure if that's what motivates me. I'm not sure if the approval of anyone else is what motivates me.
所以如果我失去了这件作品，我知道完成它需要什么，我已经知道它看起来是什么样子了，为什么我会再做一次？激励因素会是什么？那是为了让别人能看到它吗？我不确定那是否是激励我的因素。我不确定别人的认可是否是激励我的因素。
If I had known that there would be those kind of sacrifices, I probably wouldn't have done it. But as they came up, it was sort of like, as you cross that road, you decide if you're going to jump over it or if you're going to retreat. And every time, I found that I would jump over it.
如果我知道会有那种牺牲，我可能不会做。但当它们出现时，它就像是，当你穿过那条路时，你决定是要跳过去还是退缩。每一次，我发现我都会跳过去。
Life is so-- there's so much chaos. I think that one of the great solutions to dealing with that chaos is to have a mission, to have some kind of purpose. That's sort of the way I deal with why I'm here, is to make every square inch something meaningful. My materials happen to speak of that, because they are so slow and painstaking. And I have all this time to think about purpose, and why am I doing this, and is this a meaningful thing to be doing? Everything has meaning. That's the philosophy of my work. Absolutely everything has meaning if you give it meaning.
生活是如此——有太多的混乱。我认为处理这种混乱的最伟大的解决方案之一是有一个使命，有一种目标。这就是我处理我为什么在这里的方式，就是让每一平方英寸都变得有意义。我的材料恰好说明了这一点，因为它们如此缓慢而费力。我有所有这些时间思考目的，为什么我要这样做，这是有意义的事情吗？一切都有意义。这就是我作品的哲学。绝对一切都有意义，如果你赋予它意义的话。
I had this thing up in my studio. And also it's a loft. So I was having something repaired. And the repairman came inside and was fixing my washer and dryer. And he looked at my kitchen, and it was almost finished. So it was really what you're looking at, just about, maybe minus a tile or too. He put his hands on his hips. He said, neat hobby. [LAUGHS]
我的工作室里有个东西。而且那是一个阁楼。所以我有一些东西要修理。修理工进来，正在修理我的洗衣机和烘干机。他看着我的厨房，它快做完了。所以它基本上就是你看到的那个样子，也许少了一块瓷砖。他双手叉腰。他说：“挺好的业余爱好。”[笑声]
Liza Lou's kitchen is currently on display in a museum in Minneapolis. And she's working on a beaded backyard, including a million beaded blades of grass.
丽莎·娄的厨房目前正在明尼阿波利斯的一家博物馆展出。她正在做一个珠饰后院，包括一百万个珠饰草叶。
Well, Paul Tough, thank you for co-hosting and sitting here for this hour with me.
好吧，保罗·塔夫，谢谢你和我一起主持这一小时的节目。
Well, thank you, Ira.
嗯，谢谢你，艾拉。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel, Paul Tough, and myself, with Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Original vibraphone music today, written and performed by Carrie Biolo.
我们今天的节目是由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔、保罗·塔夫和我制作的，还有彼得·克劳尼、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。今天的原创颤音琴音乐由嘉莉·比奥洛创作并演奏。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like a copy of this program, it's only $10. Call us to get that at WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number is 312-832-3380. If you want to leave screams, stories about screams, or thoughts about screams for the Institute for Scream Studies, call 312-832-3326, and we will pass those along. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果你想要一份本节目的拷贝，只需10美元。打电话给芝加哥的WBEZ订购。电话号码是312-832-3380。如果你想为尖叫研究中心留下尖叫声、关于尖叫的故事或对尖叫的思考，请拨打312-832-3326，我们将转达这些信息。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected] 。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。